we welcome you back to san diego
as the padres and seattle mariners get
ready for
a double header today from pecto park in
san diego
game one between the mariners and padres
coming your way
as the padres featured nelson lamet
today in game one for a 2-1 record with
a minuscule 1.89 era coming into a 45
strikeouts in
only 33 in the third innings and
arguably coming off his
best start last year in last august
against the seattle mariners 12
strikeouts
only allowing two hits two and nothing
right away to crawford
right now the sixth best earned run
averages crawford turns on this 96 mile
an hour heater
he's a board of the leadoff single got a
good count took advantage of it
one out one on for the mariners here in
the top of the first inning and here is
kyle lewis
he's in a stretch right now where he's
hit safely in nine straight games
heading into
today's game and a grounder down to
third machado will try to start it for
two
second for one on to first a double play
nicely done around the horn
inning ending padres are coming up
connor worth
what can you do for an encore wow
that's the corner cronenworth caught
looking so that is strikeout number two
for l.j newsom and he's retired five
padres hitters in a row the start of the
ball game
so it is first and second with nobody
out
[Applause]
swinging a miss that'll work and there
you go on the slider he strikes out jp
crawford first k of the day
for lumet couldn't have come at a better
time one down one out runners uh
first and second brings up sam hagerty
swing and a miss on a pitch headed down
and in
back-to-back strikeouts for lameet two
down here in the third inning
and you know what when he needs some
strikeouts he goes to the slider
and uh this is just tying up the seattle
mariners
two down and here is kyle lewis swing
and a miss and lumet
strikes out lewis that was very
impressive
one out here in the third and josh
naylor coming up
through the shift and into right field a
base hit for josh
naylor first base runner to reach today
for the padres it's a one out single for
josh naylor
here on the bottom of the third inning
josh naylor stays on that
nicely marmal left hand hitter had a
nice spring
lifted far and deep out to left how
about this it's gone jose marmaleos
begins the game on the bench now smacks
a two-run home run first runs today from
either side of the mariners in front in
the fourth inning
there's fraley it's the mariners who
strike first and now a little pop-up
out goes tatis over one shoulder and
cannot catch it it glances off the glove
he got twisted up one over one shoulder
then the other
and shallow left and it goes off the
glove and reaching in first base would
be jake fraley
shedlong jr who walked in the third
second played appearance against lumet
2-1 pitch
swung on hit hard base hit right field
freely good runner he's going to come
around to score easily
and shed long with an rbi single and the
mariners have a three-nothing lead in
the fourth
and here's manny machado drives one
towards deep left center field back goes
lewis at the wall
that ball is gone into the ball pan home
run for manny machado his ninth of the
year
and the padres are on the board newsome
who had given up just one head
gives up a big hit here to the nl player
of the week
and manny machado 02
and a swinging miss lament with a good
bounce back inning one two three inning
with two k's
it's 3-1 seattle back to the top of the
lineup for the padres
cuts right through a pitch on the edge
grisham
oh for three today miss savage has
retired all four that he's faced
el tates had a tough time against the
starter
lj newsome and he hits a high drive a
deep left field down towards the pole
that ball is up and it is gone
on top of the western metal supply
company building
fernando tatis jr has left the field
literally home run number 13 of the year
for fernando tatis jr and the padres are
back within a run
here's maddie machado high drive deep
left field manny machado with one swing
of the bat
ties the score on his second home run of
the day
padres come back from a three-run
deficit tying up
three to three first tatis then machado
they go
back-to-back to tie it up so here is
left fielder sam
hagerty pass
and into right field for a base hit
gordon scores
and sam hagerty has given the mariners
a 4-3 lead in the 7th and here is kyle
lewis
[Applause]
and a left field pass tatis for a base
hit
crawford is in to score hagerty moves
into third base and with that the
mariners extend the lead
to two runners on the corners for kyle
seeger
the 2-2 pulled quickly on the ground
into right field hagerty scores
and the mariners pushed three across
this inning they now lead it
six to three in the seventh and austin
nola about to climb in the box here
it's a hangar out to left field
catches made by profar kyle lewis is on
his way home
and scores standing making now a 7-3
mariners lead after that sac fly by
austin nolan the tying run
will come to the plate for the padres
and manny machado
line to left field and a base hit for
machado from third base comes hedges
around from second comes grisham and two
runs are in for the padres it's now
seven to five manny machado with his
third hit of the day
drives in two more four rbi's on the day
for manny
two on two out trailing by two
hosmer represents the winning run this
will get away
from third base comes tatis he will
score and it's a one run game it's now
7-6
tying run 90 feet away hosmer sends it
into right field base head
here comes manny machado and the padres
have tied it up
7-7 winning run 90 feet away
at hosmer myers all for three today
myers to left field deep far
very good a walk-off home run
this edition of the san diego padres is
simply
unbelievable